Students end up being better qualified for whatever comes next,...
...more enriched as individuals, cross-culturally aware.
And that's what we wanna do as educators,...
...is have our students as well-positioned as possible for the lives that they will lead.
You are America's critical leaders to the global exchange community.
You ensure a positive exchange experience by identifying host families in schools...
...and by providing cross-cultural training, guidance, support, and so much more.
The purpose of this conversation and the conference that we're here in today is to pull schools into the forefront...
...and set up that partnership because they're in the education business.
They're concerned about global competencies and other cultural education,...
...but it enables us to build a partnership that makes all those kinds of things work together.
I think it's very important now that you start a relationship with the school district on who is the contact person...
...and then ask them some questions about what is their perception of...
...what a foreign exchange student is and what is the role of a volunteer,...
...and see what their perceptions are, and you can work with those.
Walking the halls was not enough.
They needed engagement.
And so, not only did I have them engaged in my classes as far as speaking on particular topics,...
...but I invited the faculty to have them for their classes.
To be able to get to that at the middle school age is vital.
They can go and be an exchange student, and they can go learn that new language,...
...and yes, it's okay that they don't know it all before they go.
So if this is something that they really wanna consider,...
...not only do we need to talk to them, but we need to get it in front of their parents.
I wish more people would see it as an essential component to life and to education.
Our young people are our new policy makers, and so they need to be incorporated in this...
...and have some experience of exchange and understanding at a young age.
We need, as an organization, to do much better in not only reaching out but listening and learning from our own teachers.
The goodwill, generosity, and mutual understanding fostered through exchange programs...
... are critical to meeting the challenges of today's world.